c'est au bord de la crise moucaye à une
rivière qui coule entre iracoubo argana
beau que cette salle est la sgm g la sng
la société guyanaise de matières grasses
qui depuis le mois d'octobre avec de
l'huile pas de l'huile d'arachide ni de
tournesol comme celles qu'on trouve
habituellement met de l'huile de palme
de war and end et plus précisément une
huile qui se lancent et producteur
revient moins cher à l'utilisation
l'avantagé de cette huile c'est nul qui
résiste à entre 200 et 230 degrés en
température comme vous faites des pauses
en général des fritures pour toujours
des frites par exemple à 180 degrés donc
vous avez encore une marge de chauffage
de cette huile et ce qui est intéressant
au niveau économique c'est que l'on peut
resservir du même bien plus plusieurs
fois a contrario d'autres huiles
après quelques bains est obligé de la
deûle a changé moins cher de la cuisine
mais aussi moins chers au magasin en
moyenne un franc de moins chez les
chinois car c'est surtout chez les
chinois que l'on trouve bull free your
l'huile d'iracoubo dans les supermarchés
lui le frayeur à un problème elle ne
supporte pas la climatisation
parce qu'il fait trop froid elle se
trouble elle prise 19 juillet c'est à
dire qu'elle devient blanchâtre cela ne
nuit pas de ses qualités affirme la jmj
mais dans les rayons ça fait mauvais
effet c'est pourquoi les indie racoupeau
en test en ce moment un nouveau procédé
de fabrication
c'est en 1992 que cette usine a été
construite mais victor père et fils sont
dans l'huile de palme depuis toujours
le père a travaillé en afrique puis en
nouvelle guinée avant de s'installer en
equateur c'est donc d'équateur qu'elle
est importé la matière première de
l'huile brute de war and end et une fois
raffiné en obtient en plus de l'huile
d'autres matières grasses qui donne du
savon de la margarine et c'est cette
double utilisation qui explique en
partie le prix de vente plus bas un prix
de vente qui devrait encore baisser
lorsque l'huile brute ne sera plus à
porter mais fabriqué ici et à la jmj en
s'y prépare on l'a déjà mis en pot 25
mille pieds d'eau arad ndé et dans
quelques années ils produiront leurs
premières gouttes d'huile
[Musique]